other news I had a caption for that
video but everyone got mad at me
well video will be like fortnight oh
yeah what was it I was like when your
wife is about to leave to hang out with
her boyfriend yeah and like you're just
sitting on the couch I got to you yeah
who likes porn I like for tonight I like
for tonight I like for tonight okay
no no there's nobody in the room it's
after she leaves she's like I'm just
going to the gym and you're like what is
11 p.m. and she's like I know it's like
a night session you're like okay fine
bye honey love you bye door closes I
just imagine her pulling a Nintendo
switch like out of a drawer yeah like
when her boyfriend comes over all right
honey
flossing [ __ ] no boyfriends like all
right pretty good at that man's like I
know I know I just I love the game I
love it I love it
give me the switch yeah who are you
that's a pretty cool skin you got there
1,200 bucks but thank you thank you like
35 your old man super excited my
boyfriend's like how old is he Oh 43 43
yeah oh my god man I saw some tweet
about like there's a while ago some
girls like if your boyfriend's older
than 23 and still gets excited about
video games get you a new man eyes okay
[ __ ] that [ __ ] you miserable [ __ ] you
you can still you can get excited about
video games and still get excited about
[ __ ] that matter yeah you can be a grown
man like video games yeah you can't you
can you can yeah you can you give me a
grown man's just yeah being a twitch
streamer this is just for our own
like who are we convincing here yeah our
selves no it's no can you can it's
totally cool
that tweet sucks yeah and that's a
miserable woman and yeah you can all
right it's totally normal goddamn it
dude I love honey it's time for dinner
please put it away no I know I'm in the
middle of a game now just turn it off
just save Kate save mom I mean babe babe
[ __ ] honey I can't let's try a I've been
trying to troll on stream I'll just
queue about fortnight and let's try
being different people I was doing like
students like [ __ ] talking mark Wiens it
was pretty fun oh hey look at that you
just got your little boy cheese class
hello everyone it is mark Wiens here
this is a fat laser back to the lobby
for you sir you are terrible at this
game I like it yeah that's good good I
want to do it or just like I was doing
like a cocky dad mm-hmm it's like trying
to sound like you're 45 plain fortnight
your lingo sucks but you're really good
oh that is a crew wife right there whole
crew gone I love that just a little bit
off like it's almost there that's the
funniest [ __ ] in the world to me that's
where the whole foreign guy that [ __ ]
came from what do you mean I mean like
when I see what I used to do this
character on snapchat like Poncho's
tacos and [ __ ] like that yeah it's from
the from Family Guy when the foreign
dudes like oh man last night man wee man
today I woke up man so hang over dude
last night I said drive 23 litres of
beer that's like litres of beer crew way
Wow Wow
got him squad ghosted jeez Louise
somebody says they're good I think
Johnny's telling fibs Johnny's telling
stop telling fibs Johnny
no more fib telling huh
Johnny telling lies I don't know the
[ __ ] meme like 3d cartoon I have no
idea what you're talking about
oh wow you really are a dad right yeah
I've not seen that I have not seen that
yet the Johnny telling fibs let's let's
go one more about that one
Johnny telling fibs all right what do
you mean brother
using Daquan [ __ ] but just go through
the wall
so we're I was you know trying to troll
some dudes and they weren't going for it
cuz they were Spanish so like they
didn't fully understand what the [ __ ]
we were like they just thought it was my
voice okay anyway they're English it was
decent I wasn't great but of the little
English they knew they were just
impersonating Daquan they kept quoting
Daquan it was crazy really yeah like Oh
what do you mean brother like just like
that's more Swedish Calum right there
I'm trying to think of like how they say
you mean brother
what do you mean brother good evening
everyone
give me your head boy now it is crazy
they're potent take one give me that
booty thank you for applying fortnight's
with me like a man what do you mean
brother
and I can't I can't hear this I just got
back to Swedish yeah they kept calling
Dave one like what do you mean brother
they just kept saying that
what do you mean brother that's crazy
yeah he's his reach anyway we've reached
our four night quota now for the next we
can't talk about it again for the next
two months no it's fine we you know what
about it I mean if we just make it [ __ ]
night I'm saying we just if we make it
[ __ ] night then it's fine mm-hmm you
know got you as long as it's making fun
of liking for tonight man-child's yeah
man but it is okay to like video games
and be and be excited about them when
you're older than 21 yeah this I've got
some clothes
[Music]
is that Dustin phone these are custom
plump these are Dustin home these are
dust